[موسيقى]
توافد مئات الالاف من البريطانيين الى هذا
المكان من اجل رؤيه او لمح او حتى القاء
التحيه على الملك تشارلز والملكه كاملا
خلال المسييرتين اللتين مرتين من هذا
الطريق الواصل بين دير وقصر بوكينج
العائله الملكيه البريطانيه التي يعود
تاريخها الى اكثر من الف عام حافظت على
اهميتها بين البريطانيين على الاقل بين
الغالبيه المتجمعه في هذا المكان
منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى وعلى صوت ترانيم
كنيسه وستور وصلت افواج المدعوين وعلى
اطراف الطريق المؤدي للقصر اصطفى الالاف
من الناس لمشاهده مواكب الحرس الملكي تجول
العاصمه البريطانيه
بعضهم خيم هنا منذ ايام واخرون تفننوا
بملابس تزينها الاعلام البريطانيه فيما
ارتدى اخرون التيجان الملكيه وحملوا
الاعلام احتفالا
كان عليها ارتداء هذه البلده القديمه
انتظرت تتويج الملك فقط حتى اتمكن من
ارتدائها
ولم يقتصر الحضور على البريطانيين فقط
وانما جاء اخرون من مختلف دول العالم كان
من الملفت كثره الاستراليين بينهم
احضرت علم الاسترالي واشتريت تاج هذا من
المتجر وهو مثالي لهذا الجو الماطر
الاجواء العامه رائعه ولا اصدق عدد
الاشخاص الموجودين هنا
فحدث كهذا يستدعي هذا الكم من الحراسه
خاصه وانه تتويج غير مسبوق بالنسبه
للبريطانيين الذين لم تشهد الاغلبيه منهم
حفل تتويش على راس العرش البريطاني منذ 70
عاما
وحتى الامطار التي لم تتوقف منذ الصباح لم
تمنعهم من الحضور
الامطار لم تزعجنا على الاطلاق الكل يقضي
وقتا ممتعا يعيش الملك
الاستعداد لهذا الاحتفال استغرق اسابيع
ليقدموا للبريطانيين وللعالم مراسم تتويش
ابهرت كل من شاهدها من لندن عروب عبد الحق
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات